good morning Hank it's Friday I hope
that you can see this this is the rare
live show that Hank is actually watching
so today's video I'm going to read to
you Chapter two of my new book The Fault
in Our Stars which my publisher was very
kind to allow me to do so thank you
penguin for letting me read nerdfighters
chapter two if you haven't read chapter
one or if you haven't heard me read
chapter one then chapter two probably
will make a lot of sense there is a link
in the doobly-doo where you can watch
and listen to chapter one or read it if
you prefer you know real text so I have
previous permission from Hank for this
so don't try to punish me I know you
guys like to punish me it's not gonna
work don't try this is gonna be a long
video what can I say
chapter two um for those of you I will
give you one brief thing this book this
book is about two kids hazel and
Augustus they met at this horrible
cancer kid support group and he said you
should really see the movie V for
Vendetta because you look exactly like V
for Vendetta
Erin Natalie Portman and she was like
alright I'll look it up and he was like
now you should go home and watch it with
me at my house right now and she feeling
sort of daring does so all right here we
go I'm kind of nervous I haven't read
this out loud ever so I apologize if I'm
bad except for what I did it for the
audiobook other than that I've never
read it out loud okay Augustus waters
drove horrific alee weather stopping or
starting everything happened with a
tremendous jolt
I flew against the seat belt of his
Toyota SUV each time he braked and my
neck snapped backward each time he hit
the gas I might have been nervous what
with sitting in the car of a strange boy
on the way to his house keenly aware
that my crap lungs complicate efforts to
fend off unwanted advances but his
driving was so astonishingly poor that I
could think of nothing else we'd gone
perhaps a mile in jagged silence before
Augustus said I failed the driving test
three times you don't say he laughed
nodding well I can't feel
journaled prosti and i can't get the
hang of driving left-footed my doctors
say that most amputees can drive with no
problem but yeah not me anyway I go in
for my fourth driving test and it goes
about like this is going a half mile in
front of us a light turned red
Augustus slammed on the brakes tossing
me into the triangular embrace of the
seatbelt sorry I swear to god I'm trying
to be gentle right so anyway at the end
of the test I totally thought I'd failed
again but the instructor but the
instructor was like you're driving is
unpleasant but it isn't technically
unsafe I'm not sure I agree I said I
suspect cancer perk cancer perks are the
little things cancer kids get that
regular kids don't
basketballs signed by sports heroes free
passes on late homework unearned
driver's licenses etc yeah he said the
light turned green I braced myself
Augustus slammed the gas you know
they've got hand controls for people who
can't use their legs I pointed out yeah
he said maybe someday he sighed in a way
that made me wonder whether he was
confident about the existence of someday
I knew osteosarcoma was highly curable
but still there are a number of ways to
establish someone's approximate survival
expectations without actually asking I
used the classic so are you in school
generally your parents pull you out of
school at some point if they expect you
to bite it yeah he said I'm in North
Central a year behind though on the
sophomore you
I considered lying no one likes a corpse
after all but in the end I told the
truth no my parents withdrew me three
years ago three years he asked
astonished
I told Augustus the broad outline of my
miracle diagnosed with stage-four
thyroid cancer when I was 13 I didn't
tell him that the diagnosis came three
months after I got my first period like
congratulations you're a woman now die
the cancer was we were told incurable I
had a surgery called radical neck
dissection which is about as pleasant as
it sounds then radiation then they tried
some chemo for my lung tumors the tumor
shrank
then grew by then I was 14 my lungs
started to fill up with water I was
looking pretty dead my hands and feet
ballooned my skin cracked my lips were
perpetually blue they've got this drug
that makes you not feel so completely
terrified about the fact that you can't
breathe and I had a lot of it flowing
into me through a PICC line and more
than a dozen other drugs besides but
even so there's a certain unpleasantness
to drowning particularly when it occurs
over the course of several months I knew
I had a text from Laureen I'm not even
going to read it until I finish this but
even so there's a certain unpleasantness
to drowning particularly when it occurs
over the course of several months I
finally ended up in the ICU with
pneumonia and my mom knelt by the side
of my bed and said are you ready sweetie
and I told her I was ready and my dad
just kept telling me he loved me in this
voice that was not breaking so much is
already broken and I kept telling him
that I loved him too and everyone was
holding hands and I couldn't catch my
breath and my lungs were acting
desperate gasping pulling me out of the
bed trying to find a position that could
get air and I was embarrassed by their
desperation disgusted that they just
wouldn't let go and I remember my mom
telling me it was okay that I was okay
that I would be okay and my father was
trying so hard not to sob that when he
did which was regularly it was an
earthquake and I remember wanting not to
be awake everyone figured I was finished
but my cancer dr. Maria managed to get
some of the fluid out of my lungs and
shortly thereafter the antibiotics
they'd given me for the pneumonia kicked
in I woke up and soon got into one of
those experimental trials that are
famous in the republic of cancer vania
for not working
the drug was phalanxifor this molecule
designed to attach itself to cancer
cells and slow their growth it didn't
work in about 70 percent of people but
it worked in me the tumor shrank and
they stayed shrunk huzzah phalanxifor in
the past 18 months my Mets have hardly
grown leaving me with lungs that suck at
being lungs but could conceivably
struggle along indefinitely with the
assistance of driz
doxygen and daily phalanxifor admittedly
my cancer miracle had only resulted in a
bit of purchase time I did not yet know
the size of the bit but when telling
Augustus waters I painted the rosiest
possible picture embellishing the
miraculousness of the miracle so now you
go so now you got to go back to school
he said I actually can't I explained
because I already got my GED so I'm
taking classes at MCC which was this
Community College a college girl he said
nodding that explains the aura of
sophistication he smirked at me I shoved
his arm playfully I could feel the
muscle right beneath the skin all tense
and amazing
we made a wheels screeching turn into a
subdivision with 8 foot high stucco
walls his house was the first one on the
left
a two-story colonial we jerked to a halt
in his driveway I followed him inside a
wooden plaque in the entryway was
engraved in cursive with the words home
is where the heart is and the entire
house turned out to be festoon Din such
observations good friends are hard to
find and impossible to forget read an
illustration above the coatrack true
love is born from hard times promised a
needlepointed pillow in their antique
furnished living room augustus saw me
reading my parents call them
encouragement s' he said they're
everywhere his mom and dad called him
Gus they were making enchiladas in the
kitchen a piece of stained glass by the
sink read in bubbly letters family is
forever
his mom was putting chicken into
tortillas which his dad then rolled up
and placed into a glass pan they didn't
seem too surprised by my arrival which
made sense the fact that Augustus made
me feel special
did not necessarily indicate that I was
special maybe he brought home a
different girl every night to show her
movies and feel her up this is hazel
grace he said by way of introduction
just hazel I said how's it going hazel
that's Gus's dad he was tall almost as
tall as Gus and skinny in a way that
parentally aged people usually aren't
okay I said how is Isaac support group
it was incredible
Gus said
you're such a debbie downer his mom said
hazel do you enjoy it
I paused a second trying to figure out
if my response should be calibrated to
please Augustus or his parents most of
the people are really nice I finally
said that's exactly what we found with
families at Memorial when we were in the
thick of it with Gus's treatment his dad
said everybody was so kind strong to in
the darkest days the Lord puts the best
people into your life quick give me a
throw pillow and some thread because
that needs to be an encouragement
Augustus said and his dad looked a
little annoyed but then Gus wrapped his
long arm around his dad's neck and said
I'm just kidding dad I like the freakin
encouragement I really do I just can't
admit it because I'm a teenager his dad
rolled his eyes you're joining us for
dinner
I hope asked his mom she was small and
brunette and vaguely mousy I guess I
said I don't have to be home by 10:00 oh
I have to be home by 10:00
oh good I thought that was a mistake for
a second I was nervous I guess I said I
have to be home by 10:00 also I don't um
eat meat no problem we'll just
vegetarian as some she said animals are
just too cute Gus asked I want to
minimize the number of deaths I'm
responsible for I said Gus opened his
mouth to respond but then stopped
himself his mom filled the silence well
I think that's just wonderful
they talked to me for a bit about how
the enchiladas were famous waters
enchiladas not to be missed
and about how Gus's curfew was also ten
and how they were inherently distrustful
of anyone who gave their kids curfews
other than ten and was I in school she's
a college student augustus interjected
and how the weather was truly and
absolutely extraordinary for March and
how in spring all things are new and
they didn't even ask once about the
oxygen or my diagnosis which was weird
and wonderful and then Augustus said
hazel and I are going to watch V for
Vendetta so she can see her filmic
doppelganger mid 2000s Natalie Portman
the living room TV is yours for the
watching his dad said happily I think
we're actually going to watch it in the
basement
his dad laughed good try living room but
I want to show hazel
race the basement augustus said just
hazel i said so
show just hazel the basement said his
dad and then come upstairs and watch
your movie in the living room augustus
puffed out his cheeks balanced on his
augustus puffed out his cheeks balanced
on his leg and twisted his hips throwing
the prosthetic forward fine he mumbled I
followed him down carpeted stairs to a
huge basement bedroom a shelf at my eye
level reached all the way around the
room and it was stuffed solid with
basketball memorabilia dozens of
trophies with gold plastic men mid jump
shot or dribbling or reaching for a
layup toward an unseen basket there were
also lots of signed balls and sneakers I
used to play basketball he explained you
must have been pretty good I wasn't bad
but all the shoes and balls are cancer
perks he walked toward the TV where a
huge pile of DVDs and video games were
arranged into a vague pyramid shape he
bent at the waist and snatched up V for
Vendetta I was like the prototypical
white Hoosier kid he said I was all
about resurrecting the lost art of the
mid range jumper but then one day I was
shooting free throws just standing at
the foul line of the north central gym
shooting from a rack of balls and all at
once I couldn't figure out why I was
methodically tossing a spherical object
through a toroidal object it seemed like
the stupidest thing I could possibly be
doing I started I started thinking about
little kids putting a cylindrical peg
through a circular hole and how they do
it over and over again for months when
they figure it out and how basketball
was basically just a slightly more
aerobic version of that same exercise
anyway for the longest time I just kept
sinking free throws I hit 80 in a row my
all-time best but as I kept going I felt
more and more like a two-year-old and
then for some reason I started to think
about hurdlers are you okay I'd taken a
seat on the corner of his unmade bed I
wasn't trying to be suggestive or
anything I just got kind of tired when I
had to stand a lot I'd stood in the
living room and then there had been the
stairs and then more standing which was
quite a lot of standing for me and I
didn't want to faint or anything I was a
bit of a Victorian lady
fainting was I'm fine I said just
listening hurdlers ya hurdlers I don't
know why I started thinking about them
running their hurdle races and jumping
over these totally arbitrary objects
that had been set in their path and I
wondered if heard words ever thought you
know this would go faster if we got rid
of the hurdles this was before your
diagnosis
I asked right well there was that too he
smiled with half his mouth the day of
the existentially fraught free-throws
was coincidentally also my last day of
dual legged Ness I had a weekend between
when they scheduled the amputation and
when it happened my own little glimpse
of what Isaac is going through I nodded
I liked Augustus waters I really really
liked him I liked the way his story
ended with someone else I liked his
voice I liked that he took existentially
fraught free throws I liked that he I
liked that he was a tenured professor in
the Department of slightly crooked
smiles with a dual appointment in the
Department of having a voice that made
my skin feel more like skin and I liked
that he had two names
I've always liked people with two names
because you get to make up your mind
about what you call them Gus or Augustus
me I was always just hazel univ eylandt
hazel give siblings
I asked huh he answered seeming a little
distracted you said that thing about
watching kids play oh yeah no I have
nephews from my half sisters but they're
older they're like dad how old are you
and Martha 28 they're like 28 they live
in Chicago they're both married to very
fans're very fancy lawyer dudes or
banker dudes I can't remember you have
siblings I shook my head no so what's
your story
he asked sitting down next to me at a
safe distance I already told you my
story I was diagnosed when no not your
cancer story your story
interests hobbies passions weird
fetishes etc um I said don't tell me
you're one of those people who becomes
their disease I know so many people like
that it's disheartening like cancer is
in the growth
right the taking people over business
but surely you haven't let it succeed
prematurely it occurred to me that
perhaps I had I struggled with how to
pitch myself to Augustus waters which
enthusiasms to embrace and in the
silence that followed it occurred to me
that I wasn't very interesting I'm
pretty unexpected out of hand
think of something you like the first
thing that comes to mind um reading what
do you read everything from like hideous
romance too pretentious fiction to
poetry whatever do you write poetry - no
I don't write there
Augustus almost shouted hazel grace you
were the only teenager in America who
prefers reading poetry to writing it
that tells me so much you read a lot of
capital G great books don't you I guess
what's your favorite um I said my
favorite book by a wide margin was an
imperial affliction but I didn't like to
tell people about it sometimes you read
a book and it fills you with this weird
evangelical zeal and you become
convinced that the shattered world will
never be put back together unless and
until all living humans read the book
and then there are books like an
imperial affliction
which you can't tell people about book
so special and rare and yours that
advertising your affection feels like a
betrayal it wasn't even that the book
was so good or anything it was just that
the author Peter Van Houten seemed to
understand me in weird and impossible
ways an imperial affliction was my book
in the way my body was my body and my
thoughts were my thoughts even so I told
Augustus my favorite book is probably an
imperial affliction I said does it
feature zombies he asked no I said
stormtroopers I shook my head it's not
that kind of book he smiled
I'm gonna read this terrible book with
the boring title that doesn't contain
stormtroopers he promised and
immediately I felt like I shouldn't have
told him about it
Augustus spun around to a stack of books
beneath his bedside table he
grabbed a paperback and a pen as he
scribbled an inscription onto the title
page
he said all I ask in exchange is that
you read this brilliant and haunting
novelization of my favorite video game
he held up the book which was called the
price of dawn I laughed and took it our
hands kind of got muddled together in
the book hand off and then he was
holding my hand cold
he said pressing a finger to my pale
wrists not cold so much as
under-oxygenated I said I love it when
you talk medical to me he said he stood
and pulled me up with him and did not
let go of my hand until we reached the
stairs I'm gonna move the light because
the light is bad it's in my face it
hurts so I'm going over here and we'll
see if that's better or worse because
the light it's too much light for the
rest of chapter 2 you will have this
vastly different frankly inferior
background but it'll be better for my my
head which you know is important yeah
this background is in every way worse I
just made I just made the video so much
worse
I apologize right so then they walk up
the stairs and we shall move all we
watched the movie with several inches of
couch between us I did the total middle
school ething when I put my hand on the
couch about halfway between us to let
him know that it was okay to hold it but
he didn't try an hour into the movie
Augustus his parents came in and served
us the enchiladas which we ate on the
couch and they were pretty delicious the
movie was about this heroic guy in a
mask who died heroically for Natalie
Portman who is pretty badass and very
hot and does not have anything
approaching my puffy steroid face as the
credits rolled he said pretty great huh
pretty great I agreed although it wasn't
really it was kind of a boy movie I
don't know why boys expect us to like
boy movies we don't expect them to like
girl movies I should get home class in
the morning I said I sat on the couch
for a while as Augustus searched for his
keys his mom sat down next to me and
said I just love this one don't you
I guess I have been looking toward the
encouragement above the TV a drawing of
an angel with the caption without pain
how could we know joy this is an old
argument in the field of thinking about
suffering and it's stupidity and lack of
sophistication could be plumbed for
centuries but suffice it to say that the
existence of broccoli does not in any
way affect the taste of chocolate yes I
said a lovely thought
I drove Augustus his car home with a
Gustus riding shotgun he played me a
couple songs by a band he liked called
the hectic glow and they were pretty
good songs but because I didn't know
them already they weren't as good to me
as they were to him
I kept glancing over at his leg or the
place where his leg had been trying to
imagine what the fake leg looked like I
didn't want to care about it but I did a
little he probably cared about my oxygen
illness repulses I'd learned that a long
time ago and I suspected Augustus had to
as I pulled up outside of my house
Augustus clicked the radio off the air
thickened he was probably thinking about
kissing me and I was definitely thinking
about kissing him wondering if I wanted
to
I'd kissed boys but it had been a while
pre-miracle I put the car in park and
looked over at him he really was
beautiful I know boys aren't supposed to
be but he was hazel grace he said my
name new and better in his voice it has
been a real pleasure to make your
acquaintance ditto mr. waters I said I
felt shy looking at him I could not
match the intensity of his water blue
eyes may I see you again he asked there
was an endearing nervousness in his
voice I smiled sure tomorrow
he asked patience grasshopper I
counseled you don't want to seem
overeager right that's why I said
tomorrow he said I want to see you again
tonight but I'm willing to wait all
night and much of tomorrow I rolled my
eyes I'm serious he said you don't even
know me
I said I grabbed the book from the
center console how about I call you when
I finished this but you don't even have
my phone number he said I strongly
suspect you wrote it in the book he
broke out into that big goofy smile and
you say we don't know each other that's
the second chapter of The Fault in Our
Stars my new book which comes out on
January 10 which is in like 48 something
very soon um I hope you guys like it the
that's the first chapter of like 26
chapters so don't feel spoiled or
anything you still have you know I'm
really bad at math at least at least 12
thirteenth's of the book to read um but
there is also you can also read that in
text at scribd.com um so I will put
there will be that link in the
doobly-doo as well as links in the
doobly-doo to listen to chapter 1 and
all the places you can pre-order the
book whatever whatever and then also oh
yeah if you want to hear me read this
whole thing the only way to do that is
via the special DVD boxset that i talked
about in my last video
thanks to brilliant audio for making
that possible so there's a link in the
doobly-doo to that as well um I hope you
guys yeah I really hope you guys enjoy
the rest of the book and yeah those it's
been a lot of fun to work on but I'm
really excited to to share it with you
really excited that it's not going to be
just my thing anymore so sorry for the
long video I did go a bit over my
four-minute limit but again I have
permission from Hank so please you know
take your punishment daggers put them
back in the sheath and I'm gonna go read
my dirty texts from Maureen Johnson but
I will talk to you later
something is happening over here at the
printer so I'm going to go dftba
best wishes
you